こんにちははじめシャツをレストルームで私はじめシャツをもうさすがにしている人が
多いと思うんですけども東京2020オリンピックを応援するチームコカコーラに任命
されましたトレヴで今日はもう
スポーツを研究していこうと思います今日するのはこちら
象強力な扇風機を8コ準備いたしました
北スポーツ匂い
ですね結構風の影響って大きいと思うんですよ
サッカーモナコ追い風の時は試合が変わったりとか陸上の100m とも結果負の影響
でタイムが返納したりすると思うんで
スポーツにおける風の影響とすごいでかいと思うんですよだけで今日はですねなかなか
自然現象だと怒ることが少ないような強力な風のある状況の中でいる
女スーッと行ってみようと思います時に風邪ば
味方し
的になる
それが素大帝でまず最初の競技はこちら
ヘッド誰でございますはい
間とよく数勉強となると思います
あえて風の影響である中でやることってあまりないと思うので1回フットサルサッカー
リーグやってみましょう
あのコントいってキーパーに着目してやってみましょう
など
声と思うよ y スプーンするボギーば速いん低温で魂
ボールのソロがか願っていることによってシュート内のボールの勢いが超弱まって最強
のキーパーに僕でもなれるのかなと思います
最強の請求起業するにあったらされのキーパー絶対慶州入らない穴だってみようと思い
ます
ああああああ
あれ
me
フットサルボールをもういいんで風邪な意味がないことが分かりました
全然カラー風に2に早かった球が今度はですねちょっとボールを軽くしてもいいです
こそやってみましょう
入ってるでここからちょっとカヴィヴォルったんですけどもキーパーポプラの税務富豪
らのメンバーのスーパーボウラー早くに協力者もだと思いますば踊られる運動制御
イーター
やる気しかないみたいです聞いばお願い
goo
やって解からん
ああああああ
naver
トゥーンマリから営業が関係ないような気がしました
プリキュアショーはい続いてバスケットボールをやっていきましょうボールを軽くした
方が2つめる変化がわかると思うんで軽いボールやっていこうと思いますのでご覧
くださいことがポールのましてから風が吹いてるとどうなるかという検証でございます
もう目に向かって風が向いてるんで断固としてリングに入らないぞというか
の影響があるのでかなり難易度が高いと思いますがしっかりとシュートを決めていき
たいとおもいます
それが
ni
いいいいいいいいいん
goo
行ってあげて次の日朝と思いまーぬーから協力が多い風を吹かせていただきますっっ
すごいサティ
チキですねいいえ技術ですではやっておいてもそうします
me
[拍手]
本当のめっちゃ日下での影響が顕著に出ますね楽しかったですアースカラーアイアイっ
ていうわけでここまで色々やってきたんですけども完全に一つ分かったことがあります
課税の dk をめちゃくちゃありますね
大きいですよね多い魂はあんまり意味ないんですけども軽いために感謝めちゃくちゃ
協議に影響が出るんで
最後は2人中に分かれてビーチバレー思います
ええええええ
こんなバレーボールやりでとこなんですけど風の影響がでかいということでこちらの
大きい玉を使って
っていうかと思いますこの中でこのチームになるんですけども
そっちのチームに彼方秒差いるに貼っ時代の航空機
強力な葬儀を準備しました身長的にはこちらの巻第カオスんだけど
風の力めちゃくちゃ強いからこの大きいためだと多分いい
勝負できると思うんですよ全壊した自宅マックスビアッジます珍しいです
5点成熟しましょうでパウダー国侵犯してもらってこれでどっちが2つのがやっていき
たいとおもいます
ran
ああああああ
goo
ええええええ
で関係ねーよ
ああああああああああああ
me
味が読めない風を得なかったん
telas
ああああああ
goo
me
rar
ああああああ
then when
外は風だが切るんでさぁムーン
それでフォロー狙いが本当に俺が出ません
あ政府がで0ギャルだけど
ああああああああああああ
goo
wh
[音楽]
car
ダウはロワールああああああ
うわぁというわけで皆さんどうでしたか風の影響をスポーツによってとても大事で
ございますてオリンピック皆さんもですね選手とかもとても綺麗なとこなんですけども
会場とか場所の風の影響とかあんなんていうのを
会議で言えばその環境もまたスポーツの見どころのひとつだと思います上で今回前にて
連れてくればこちらのスーパーボールラーベアクア j の加工等のメンバーでして
中国ほどの後席チャンネルで動画を出して言います
めっちゃウンド c 店員で皆さんぜひ見てみてくださいめっちゃするとつになります
からそしてチームコカコーラの youtube チャンネルイースターからめっち
頑張りますのでそちらもぜひチェックしてみてください加瀬内容はどうぞ同様欄で
ございます
はいというわけでこの他にも色んなユーチューバーが中深くボールに入っておりますの
で
スーパーポーラーベア服も含め今後も我々の活動に期待してくださいばいばい
[音楽]
me
ni
あっはぁ